[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und wir beginnen die
Sendung mit lauter Katastrophen
ausgelöst durch Hitzewellen Brände
starke Wände und Regen im Norden
Italiens gab es sogar massive Regenfälle
starke Sturmböen und Hagelschauer von
dem schweren Unwetter war insbesondere
die Metropole Mailand sowie große Teile
der Lombardei betroffen eine 16-Jährige
starb durch einen umfallenden Baum auf
Sizilien das krasse Gegenteil
Temperaturen bis 47 Grad dort kämpft die
Feuerwehr zudem gegen mehrere Waldbrände
einer kam dem Flughafen von Palermo
sogar so nah dass dieser für mehrere
Stunden geschlossen werden musste in
Algerien machen den rund 8000
Einsatzkräften auch Brände zu schaffen
die Flammen breiteten sich angesichts
starker Winde ziemlich schnell aus und
1500 Menschen mussten dort in Sicherheit
gebracht werden 34 sollen sogar ums
Leben gekommen sein
Hitzewelle und Brände gehen auch auf
griechischen Ferieninseln weiter
besonders tragisch auf der Insel eubör
ist ein Löschflugzeug abgestürzt und
beide Piloten kam dabei ums Leben auf
Rhodos sprechen die Einsatzkräfte die
wohl von 11 EU-Staaten unterstützt
werden weiterhin von einer schwierigen
Lage Andreas Postel berichtet
die Flammen kommen wieder näher die
Ortschaft mallonas im Osten von Rhodos
muss am frühen Abend zum zweiten Mal
innerhalb weniger Tage evakuiert werden
es gibt nicht genug Einsatzkräfte die
Brände unter Kontrolle zu bringen viele
helfen freiwillig
tragisch diese Situation lässt sich
nicht retten das ist das Ende wir kommen
aus dem Nachbarort und wir fahren durch
alle Dörfer und helfen wo wir können
jede Hilfe zu spät die Flammen haben ihm
die wirtschaftliche Existenz gehabt
erzählt er mir seine Bar in kyotari war
beliebt bei den Touristen jetzt steht er
vor dem Nichts muss ganz von vorne
anfangen
es ist eine große Katastrophe unsere
Geschäfte sind ausgebrannt jetzt
brauchen wir positive Energie um wieder
von vorne anzufangen und während er sich
Mut macht Flammen auch am siebten Tag in
Folge die Brände wegen der starken und
heißen Winde wieder auf Feuerwehren und
Löschflugzeuge versuchen den ganzen Tag
über die Insel von den Bränden zu
befreien
während die Hotelangestellte puppy
manicaro arbeiten muss ist auch ihr
Wohnort von den Flammen bedroht ihr Sohn
und ihr Ehemann sind gerade als
freiwillige im lösch-einsatz sie zeigt
mir stolz deren Fotos und Videos
einer meiner Söhne kämpft gegen die
Flammen mein Ehemann ebenfalls und mein
anderer Sohn verteilt Wasser und
Hilfsgüter an alle Dörfer die es
brauchen
und wie schaffen Sie das in diesen Tagen
es ist eine große Belastung aber wir
sind sehr glücklich dass wir am Leben
sind dass unsere Gäste überlebt haben
und wir machen das Menschenmögliche
ihr Hotel war eines der ersten in
Kiotari das von den Flammen bedroht
wurde und aus dem hunderte Touristen
über den Strand in Sicherheit gebracht
worden jetzt erinnern in der fünf Sterne
Lobby nur die Reisekoffer an die
Hotelgäste einige von ihnen kommen heute
aus der Notunterkunft um Ihr Gepäck vor
dem Heimflug abzuholen auch diese
Österreicherin Erlebte mit ihren Kindern
schreckliche Stunden
wir haben zu Fuß gegangen dann mit dem
Boot dann mit dem Bus nach Lindos dann
in ein Hotel wir haben jetzt seit
Samstag mit drei Kindern
mit vier Kinder insgesamt und jetzt
haben wir am Flughafen
Salzburg und jetzt haben wir mit dem
Taxi ober gefahren
während die Touristen nach Hause fliegen
bleiben die Angestellten mit der
Befürchtung zurück dass die Gäste nicht
wiederkommen und sie ihren Job verlieren
ist und dann wer weiß es nicht wer hier
von die Leute wir sprechen mit die
Chefin hier wie erwarte ich weiß es
nicht ohne ist ich weiß es nicht
auf der anderen Seite von Rhodos machen
die Touristen weiterhin Urlaub und
bekommen von den brennenden wenig zu
spüren eine zwiespältige Angelegenheit
denn einerseits hilft das dem wichtigen
Wirtschaftszweig der Insel andererseits
leiden die brandregionen nach wie vor
unter den extremen Hitze feuern dieses
Sommers
also zigtausend Touristen und Einwohner
sind aus Hotels und Dörfern in
Sicherheit gebracht worden 150
Quadratkilometer Wald und
landwirtschaftliche genutztes Land
sollen zerstört worden sein was bedeutet
das alles für Rhodos Griechenland bzw
ganz grundsätzlich für die
Urlaubsregionen am Mittelmeer das kann
uns Professor Harald Zeiss erläutern er
ist Betriebswirt war lange für den
Reisekonzern TUI tätig und forscht nun
an der Hochschule Harz Schwerpunkte sind
Nachhaltigkeit und internationaler
Tourismus ein schönen guten Abend Herr
Professor
das was wir da jetzt sehen und in Teilen
ja auch schon in den letzten Jahren
gesehen haben was bedeutet das für den
Mittelmeerraum
das bedeutet erst einmal dass die
Prognosen die im Prinzip schon seit 1979
bei der ersten Weltklimakonferenz
vorhergesagt haben jetzt langsam
eintreten das jetzt diese Feuer so
wütend und das die Touristen evakuiert
werden müssen dass sicherlich jetzt ein
Einzelfall aber insgesamt zeichnet sich
doch ein Bild dass er besorgniserregend
ist nämlich dass die Temperaturen im
gesamten Mittelmeerraum jedes Jahr etwas
steigen und diese Katastrophen damit
auch wahrscheinlicher machen und geht da
wirklich wie der in Italien Urlaub
machen der Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach auf Twitter schrieb eine
Ära zu Ende weil so schrieb er wenn es
so weitergeht diese Urlaubsziele
langfristig keine Zukunft haben
langfristig ist schwer prognostizierbar
also sicherlich wird jetzt nicht von
heute auf morgen der Tourismus in diesen
Ländern einbrechen man muss auch sagen
dass es jetzt ein singuläres Ereignis
das insbesondere davon getrieben ist
dass die brennende touristische Orte
betreffen Waldbrände gibt es dort jedes
Jahr diese haben jetzt ein sehr großes
Ausmaß und sicherlich sind die
Nachrichten die jetzt in Deutschland
ankommen für viele die einen Urlaub in
dieser Region planen doch so
besorgniserregen dass man vielleicht
noch mal drüber nachdenkt aber der
Tourismus wird nicht von heute auf
morgen einbrechen
der Gesundheitsminister hat sich für
diesen Tweet jedenfalls ordentlich Ärger
vor allen Dingen italienischen Ärger
auch eingefangen aber heißt das noch mal
nachgefragt das Touristenströme sich
schon auch verändern werden und einige
Länder möglicherweise zu verlieren
werden weil Touristen diese Hitze meiden
absolut
wenn wir Ihnen die auf die nächsten
Jahre Jahrzehnte schauen wird es im
Sommer immer wärmer werden und
insbesondere für Kinder aber auch
ältere Menschen sind diese Temperaturen
sehr schwer zu ertragen und jeder
einzelne Urlauber wird sich vor
überlegen ob es ihm oder ihr Wert ist
dann zu diesen heißen Sommern in den
Mittelmeerraum zu reisen allerdings gibt
es ja auch die vor und die Nachsaison im
Frühjahr und dem Herbst wo die
Temperaturen erträglicher sind aber wir
werden mit Sicherheit Veränderungen bei
den tourismusströmen erleben und die
werden sich sicherlich nicht im
Mittelmeerraum erhöhen sondern eher
reduzieren Problem im Frühjahr oder
Herbst gibt es nicht die Sommerferien
und das ist natürlich die Zeit die viele
nutzen haben die Länder denn eine sagen
wir mal langfristige Strategie damit
dieser Tourismus nicht ein bzw wegbricht
also für die Länder ist der Tourismus
extrem wichtig griechenland hat ungefähr
20 Prozent seines Bruttoinlandsprodukts
schöpftes aus dem Tourismus im Vergleich
zu Deutschland sind es sechs oder sieben
Prozent das heißt es eine sehr wichtige
Industrie wie dort die Strategien sind
kann ich persönlich nicht beantworten
aber man wird sich dort sehr genau
ansehen wie man Anpassungsmaßnahmen
umsetzen kann indem vielleicht durch
mehr Beschattung oder auch durch
Landstriche die etwas stärker Wind
bekommen dass es angenehmer wird für die
Touristen aber wir werden den Effekten
des Klimawandels nicht davonlaufen
können und die Frage stellt sich was
passiert wenn die Temperatur noch weiter
zunehmen eine Lösung sehe ich da aktuell
auch nicht es gibt Berechnungen zum
Beispiel aus dem italienischen
Umweltministerium da sagen Fachleute bei
einem Anstieg der durch
schnittstemperatur von zwei Grad dann
droht ein Verlust von ungefähr 15
Milliarden bei einem Anstieg um vier
Grad bis zu 52 Milliarden wenn der
Tourismus dann einbrechen sollte die
Gelder damit fehlen und vielleicht auch
durch brennende etc Anbauflächen
wegbrechen droht dann diesen Region auch
der wirtschaftliche bankrot
also von einem Bankrott würde ich
aktuell nicht sprechen es sind aber
extreme finanzielle Herausforderungen
und nicht nur für die Länder im Süden
auch für die Länder im mittleren Europa
im Prinzip für alle Länder auf der Welt
die Herausforderung die uns die
Klimakrise bringen sind
müssen finanziell aufgefangen werden
aber mit jedem Grad dass die Welt sich
erwärmt werden natürlich auch die
anpassungsausgaben deutlich erhöht und
das ist etwas was der IPC also der
Klimarat schon seit Jahren sagt jeden
Monat jeden Tag im Prinzip den wir
warten und das nicht schaffen die
Klimaemissionen zu reduzieren wird sich
am Ende die Rechnung deutlich erhöhen
und es wäre heute viel einfacher CO2
Emissionen zu reduzieren und viel
preiswerter als Sie weiterlaufen zu
lassen was aktuell leider der Fall ist
und dann irgendwann in der Zukunft die
Anpassung dann umzusetzen die deutlich
mehr kosten als die Reduktion heute und
Touristen suchen sich vielleicht andere
Gegner Gegenden wie zum Beispiel
Skandinavien
aber das ist dann wieder ein anderes
Thema Herr Professor vielen Dank für
Ihre Einschätzung
schönen Abend
Hitze und Dürre sie sorgen auch für
getreideknappheit und die wird durch den
Angriffskrieg Russlands noch verstärkt
das putinhunger als Waffe einsetzt das
sehen wir Tag für Tag er lässt nachdem
er das getreideabkommen mit der Ukraine
aufgekündigt hat verstärkt Lebensmittel
Lager und Hafenanlagen angreifen zudem
hat er vor dem Russland Afrika Gipfel
der in zwei Tagen beginnt Angeboten
ukrainisches Getreide auf kommerzieller
Basis aber auch kostenfrei zu ersetzen
und während Putin also taktiert
überlegen die EU Agrarminister wie sie
das Problem lösen können wie kriegt man
die knapp 33 Millionen Tonnen Getreide
die die Ukraine trotz Krieg über das
Schwarze Meer Verschiffen konnte in die
Welt
alternative Wege sind die über Land aber
die sind ein Tropfen auf den heißen
Stein und bringen eben auch Probleme mit
sich wie Isabel Schäfers zeigt
der slowakische Landwirt Duschen Knatsch
baut vor allem Raps und Weizen an ca 50
km entfernt von der ukrainischen Grenze
er leidet unter gesunkenen Preisen und
fehlenden Abnehmern für seine Ware der
Grund immer mehr ukrainisches Getreide
kommt in den östlichen grenzstaaten der
EU an
das ukrainische Getreide wird nicht
einfach durch unsere Länder hindurch und
weiter nach Ägypten und Afrika
transportiert sondern es bleibt hier bei
uns und dadurch ist bei uns der
Weizenpreis gesunken
ein Dilemma für die EU denn sie will die
Ukraine unterstützen ihr Getreide
vermehrt über den Landweg durch die EU
in die Welt zu bringen noch einmal mehr
seit Russland den Getreide Deal
gekündigt hat doch vor allem in den
EU-Ländern die an die Ukraine Grenzen
wie Polen Slowakei Ungarn Rumänien und
Bulgarien sorgt das für Probleme immer
gramarkt wir wollen der Ukraine helfen
aber eben unter solchen Bedingungen dass
keine Schwierigkeiten auf dem Markt für
die slowakischen Lebensmittel entstehen
um das zu erreichen bekommen die
Betroffenen osteuropäischen Bauern
derzeit Ausgleichszahlungen und die
Einfuhr einiger ukrainischer Produkte in
die betroffenen Staaten wurde beschränkt
aber die Ausnahmeregelung läuft Mitte
September aus und die Ukraine fordert
eine vollständige Öffnung der EU-Grenzen
für ihr Getreide
wir gehen davon aus dass die europäische
Seite ihre Verpflichtungen uns gegenüber
erfüllt wenn die Vorübergehenden
Importbeschränkungen nicht mehr gelten
jede Verlängerung ist absolut
inakzeptabel und ganz
und so sucht die EU nach Lösungen die
beide Seiten zufriedenstellen das
Problem ist lösbar man könnte
beispielsweise dafür sorgen dass die
Produkte aus der Ukraine verplombt an
die Häfen transportiert werden
beispielsweise im Baltikum und dann
dorthin transportiert wird was benötigt
wird in den globalen Süden wir könnten
es schaffen über die europäischen
solidaritätskorridore fassen so viel zu
exportieren wie es für die Ukraine nötig
ist
komplett kann der europäische Landweg
den Seeweg übers Schwarze Meer aber
nicht ersetzen dennoch spielte EU bei
der Verteilung von ukrainischen Getreide
eine zentrale Rolle was vielleicht nach
außen besonders wichtig wäre und auch
sehr schnell und vielleicht zu wenig
passiert zumindest strategisch
kommunikativ ein Zeichen zu setzen
dass man sich kümmert um die humanitären
Risiken eher auf den weltmärk ten die
möglicherweise entstehen um eben keinen
Vakuum für Russland zu überlassen die EU
sucht weiter nach neuen Wegen für das
ukrainische Getreide und nach einer
Balance zwischen den internen
europäischen sorgen und der
geopolitischen Aufgabe die Ukraine zu
unterstützen
und dazu später dann auch ein Gespräch
im heute journal Update mit einem
deutschen Leiter eines agrarbetriebs in
der Ukraine Dietrich Treis der die
Probleme aus seiner Sicht schildert
und wir bleiben beim Thema Krieg und
seine Auswirkungen Gundula und da gibt
es nun in Sachen Russland eine wiederum
in Sachen Wehrpflicht in Moskau hat das
Parlament die Altersgrenze für
Wehrpflichtige von 27 auf 30 Jahre
angehoben zudem dürfen junge Russen nach
Zustellung der Einberufung das Land
nicht mehr verlassen zwar werden
offiziell keine Wehrpflichtigen im Krieg
gegen die Ukraine eingesetzt doch selbst
russische Medien berichten darüber nach
ukrainischen Angaben wurde die
Hauptstadt Kiew erneut stundenlang mit
russischen Kampfdrohnen angegriffen alle
Geschosse sein abgefangen worden
zur Beschleunigung der deutschen
Militärhilfen fordert der
wissenschaftliche Beirat beim
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
Erleichterungen im Beschaffungswesen so
sollten bestimmte Verträge nicht mehr
vom Haushaltsausschuss genehmigt werden
die Vergabe müsse einfacher und
schneller werden forderte auch das
Rüstungsunternehmen Rheinmetall bei
einem Besuch von
hessensministerpräsident Rhein zugleich
ist die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie laut
Experten nicht darauf eingestellt so
schnell zu liefern wie gefordert
der seit Wochen verschwundene
Außenminister Chinas chingang ist seines
Amtes enthoben worden zuletzt war er vor
einem Monat öffentlich aufgetreten
seither wurde in China über mögliche
Motive für sein abtauchen spekuliert
Erkrankung Korruptionsermittlungen oder
private Verwicklungen ohne Angabe von
Gründen wurde nun jeans-
in Israel dauern die Proteste gegen die
umstrittene Justizreform an Ärzte und
Soldaten verweigern den Dienst
allerdings Verbot ein Arbeitsgericht den
Streik der Mediziner und selbst
Oppositionsführer Lapid rief die
Soldaten auf weiter ihren Dienst zu tun
10000 beteiligten sich vergangenen Nacht
an den Protesten bei Zusammenstößen
wurden einige Menschen verletzt es gab
dutzende Festnahmen viele Zeitungen
titelten ein schwarzer Tag für die
israelische Demokratie
das Oberste Gericht Israels dessen
Befugnisse durch die umstrittene Reform
beeinträchtigt werden sollen muss
mehrere Petitionen gegen das
verabschiedete Gesetz prüfen zum
Beispiel von der israelischen
Rechtsanwaltskammer experten warnen vor
einer Verfassungskrise
vor der Küste des Jemen hat eine heikle
Bergungsaktion begonnen die Vereinten
Nationen wollen etwa 200 Millionen Liter
Öl aus dem havarierten und schrottreifen
das Schiff ist 47 Jahre alt und droht
seit langem zu zerbrechen dann könnte
das Öl ins Rote Meer fließen um diese
Umweltkatastrophe zu verhindern wird das
Öl auf das unschiff nautika umgeleitet
die Aktion sollen 19 Tage dauern
Solarmodule für die Landwirtschaft und
zwar solche durch die man Flächen
doppelt nutzen kann es klingt ein
bisschen wie ein Blick in die Zukunft
aber agrif photovoltaikanlagen werden
bereits getestet in Rathenow in
Brandenburg wird quasi oben so
Sonnenenergie für die Stromerzeugung
gesammelt und unten drunter laufen dann
beispielsweise Kühe Hühner oder gänserum
und haben dann auch noch ein Dach über
Kopf über das zwei Fliegen mit einer
Klappe Prinzip das viele Vorteile
allerdings auch ein paar Nachteile mit
sich bringt Jan Meyer
die Rinder von Christian knees
verbringen fast das ganze Jahr auf der
Weide heute bringt sie der Landwirt in
die Versuchsanlage in Rathenow hier
sollen sie testen wie Freilandhaltung
unter Solarpaneelen funktioniert
Christian Knes will nachhaltig
Solarstrom erzeugen ohne wertvolle
Ackerfläche zu opfern
wenn wir schon eine Solaranlage auf dem
Acker bauen dann wollen wir für unsere
Teil eben auch noch die Fläche unter den
Solarmodulen machen wir sind familiärer
kleiner Betrieb oder mittlerer Betrieb
so wir wollen auch in Zukunft weiter
Landwirtschaft machen
klimaschutzminister Harbeck besuchte am
Nachmittag die Forschungseinrichtung für
Viehzucht ist genug Platz unter den
Photovoltaik Elementen in über 3 Metern
Höhe sie produzieren bei Sonne Strom und
bieten Schutz bei jedem Wetter auch für
Hühner und Gänse das Projekt soll zeigen
wie Landwirtschaft und Energieerzeugung
auf einer Fläche möglich sind das
Wachstum wenn man die Paneele richtig
anordnet ist sehr sehr gut weil die Kühe
können ganzjährig draußen bleiben die
Krankheiten gehen zurück also dass alle
spricht dafür dass das eine zukünftige
Nutzungsform auf der Fläche ist man hat
eine doppelte winsituation Ertrag und
Energie der Ausbau der Solarenergie
stößt in Brandenburg an Grenzen
Werneuchen verhängte bereits einen
Baustopp Anwohner fühlen sich bedrängt
von gleich vier Anlagen darunter ist der
größte Solarpark Deutschlands ich lebe
in einem Dorf und jeder Weg der ausführt
führt an einer PV-Anlage vorbei dann
verliert es für mich diesen lebenswerten
Charakter dieses dort ne dieses
Dorflebens das ist für mich dann
tatsächlich dann kann ich eigentlich
auch in die Stadt ziehen oben
Energiegewinnung unten Landwirtschaft
das könnte wieder für mehr Akzeptanz
sorgen in Rathenow Reifen sogar Tomaten
doch die Kosten sind fünfmal höher als
die von herkömmlichen Anlagen die
Anlagen sind ja höher sie haben
Glasmodule das sind keine Anlagen die
flächenversiegeln das sind Anlagen die
oben Licht durchlassen und
Wasser verteilen das sind Anlagen die
viel höher sind die Kosten mehr eine
solche Investition überfordert aber
viele Landwirte auch wenn die
Einspeisevergütung für Solarstrom Anfang
des Jahres deutlich erhöht wurde
eine agrypv-anlage ist natürlich um
einiges teurer im Invest als eine
standardfreiflächenanlage und deswegen
brauchen wir hier auch ein Bonus im
Erneuerbaren Energiegesetz damit diese
Sache überhaupt richtig in Gang kommt
heute in Rathenow machte Minister Habeck
jedoch wenig Hoffnung auf höhere
Fördersätze ich sehe auch umgekehrt eine
Nachfrage nach agpv und wir müssen jetzt
diese kritische Schwelle überspringen
und dann glaube ich gehen auch die
Kosten für solche Anlagen runter
Minister Habeck will den Anteil der
Solarenergie bis 2030 verdreifachen wie
groß der Beitrag von agris Solaranlagen
dafür sein wird dass ist offen
und mit Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft
geht es jetzt bei dir weiter Gundula
trotz der hohen Inflation trotz aller
corona-folgen und trotz des Krieges
zeigt sich die Weltwirtschaft insgesamt
recht robust so sieht es der
Internationale Währungsfonds nur die
deutsche Wirtschaft steht in der
aktuellen iwf-prognose nicht gut da
Stefanie berrett der Rückgang ist
demnach sogar deutlicher als erwartet ja
so deutlich sogar dass wir tatsächlich
Klassen letzter sind da werden wieder
alte Erinnerungen wach als Deutschland
schon mal der kranke Mann Europas war
während der EWF das globale Wachstum in
diesem Jahr bei drei Prozent sieht
schrumpft die deutsche Wirtschaft um 0,3
Prozent damit erzielt die Bundesrepublik
als einziger G7 Staat kein Wachstum
selbst die Südeuropäer stehen sehr viel
besser da als Deutschland sie
profitieren vom aktuellen Reisebuch und
sogar für Russland rechnet der EWF trotz
Sanktionen mit einem Plus von anderthalb
Prozent in Deutschland dagegen leidet
die Industrie unter hohen Energiekosten
und schwacher china-konjunktur zuletzt
sind die Auftragspolster weiter
geschmolzen als die iwf-prognose am
Nachmittag eintraf da ging der DAX
kurzzeitig in die Knie erholte sich aber
rasch wieder denn viele der hier
notierten Unternehmen verdienen immer
noch gut aber eben vor allem im Ausland
und gibt es denn gar keine Faktoren und
wenn welche die auf bessere Zeiten für
die deutsche Wirtschaft hoffen lassen
also die Hoffnung ruhen tatsächlich auf
dem nächsten Jahr wenn im besten Fall
die Inflation weiter zurückgeht und
Löhne und Gehälter steigen dann könnten
Wachstumsimpulse entstehen auch ein
chinesisches Konjunkturpaket könnte bei
uns wieder mehr Aufträge auslösen ob das
allerdings für eine kraftvolle Erholung
ausreicht fraglich denn die lange Liste
der strukturellen Probleme hierzulande
lässt sich kaum so schnell abarbeiten
und auch das Wirtschaftswunder der
Grünen Transformation steht noch in den
Sternen
Stefanie herzlichen Dank nach Frankfurt
immer mehr junge Menschen mit Abitur
oder Fachhochschulreife beginnen nach
der Schule eine Ausbildung ihr Anteil an
allen Auszubildenden ist von 23 Prozent
im Jahr 2011 laut Statistischen
Bundesamt innerhalb von zehn Jahren auf
knapp 30 Prozent gestiegen in einigen
Lehrberufen etwa im IT-Bereich sind
Abitur oder Fachhochschulreife fast
Voraussetzung für einen
Ausbildungsvertrag
den 6:0 Auftaktsieg der deutschen
Frauenfußball-Nationalmannschaft bei der
WM in Australien haben im ZDF im Schnitt
rund 5,6 Millionen Menschen gesehen das
war ein Marktanteil von 60 Prozent am
Montagmorgen heute gewann Deutschlands
nächster WM-Gegner Kolumbien gegen
Südkorea 2:0 kogastgeber Neuseeland
musste mit der 0 zu 1 Niederlage gegen
die Philippinen einen Rückschlag
hinnehmen und die Schweiz und Norwegen
trennten sich torlos
in Wien ziehen gratis Veranstaltungen im
Rahmen des Kultursommers tausende
Zuschauer an noch bis Mitte August gibt
es auf zahlreichen Open Air Bühnen
klassische und moderne Musik Kabarett
und Literatur Tanz und Theater und das
alles bei freien Eintritt infolge der
Pandemie hatte die Stadt das
Kulturfestival im Freien eingeführt und
Wien bleibt dabei mit einer Investition
von 4 Millionen Euro
super Sache wir bleiben beim Thema
Kultur konkret geht es jetzt um einen
Zaubergarten um einen sparen um Erlösung
Regeneration und den heiligen Gral und
schon dürfte bei den meisten von ihnen
sicherlich der Groschen gefallen sein
richtig es geht um Wagners passivball
mit diesem Werk werden in diesem Jahr
die Bayreuther Festspiele eröffnet die
Diskussionen vorab die drehen sich wie
immer eigentlich um Wagner selbst aber
auch um die gestiegenen Ticketpreise die
geringere Nachfrage und und eine
technische Erneuerung die könnte zwei
Lager zusammenbringen und zwar die die
auf die klassische Darstellung stehen
bzw bestehen und die die das Werk gerne
etwas moderner interpretiert haben
möchten allerdings kommen nicht alle die
wollen in diesem Genuss dafür reicht
dann das Geld nicht Barbara Look
als hätte es der Himmel kommen sehen
Platzregen und Wolken Türme heute zur
Premiere fast wie eine Vorhersehung da
rinnt ein Tempel um seinen Ruf um alten
Glanz um Zukunft
uns geht es schon im hohem Maße darum
diesen Mythos bereut zu erhalten
aber genau dieser Mythos wankt und die
Premiere heute spiegelt den Spagat und
die Misere
Parzival digital das Bühnengeschehen
wird dabei mit Hilfe von sogenannten
ar-brillen durch virtuelle Welten
ergänzt die Idee ist spektakulär aber es
gibt zu wenig Brillen
die allermeisten der Premieren Gäste die
also heute im Sturm über den Teppich
schreiten können den clue der
Inszenierung also gar nicht sehen weil
das Geld fehlt
also tatsächlich werden wir natürlich
schon gerne mit der Brille versehen
gewesen muss man tatsächlich sagen aber
wir haben jetzt gehört in der ersten
Pause schon dass einige mit Brille
gesagt haben na ja es hat ein bisschen
abgelenkt wir sind einige Bilder die
wirklich berauschen schön sind aber ich
kann nicht wirklich sagen dass es so
eine neue
sinngebende eben entstanden ist
zwischen
Experimentierfeld und alter Schule sucht
der Hügel seinen Kurs und neues Publikum
denn zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte
sind die Festspiele nicht ausverkauft
hinter den Kulissen fehlt die eine Linie
weil es am Ende wohl auch ein Gefecht
der Generationen und junge Wagner-Fans
wie Emilia eben noch die Ausnahme sind
diese musik weckt einfach bei mir
Emotionen Wut Leidenschaft Liebe also
jedes Mal wenn Lungen obertüre gespielt
wird fange ich schon an zu heulen
ein Theater ausschließlich gebaut für
die Werke Richard Wagners und gleichsam
so verstrickt in interne quiren
Festspiele Chefin Katharina Wagner die
sich als erneuererin sieht kämpft mit
den Traditionalisten und schweigt aber
andere die reden wir treffen einen
intimen Beobachter Bayreuth der in dem
was dort serviert wird keine Zukunft
sieht für mich ist es ein Signal für die
gesamte
opernlandschaft Deutschlands ja was
machen
wovon sie sich viel versprochen haben
erwischt die nicht da werden sie das
gleiche nicht wieder bestehen
Ende des Jahres werden die
Gesellschafter der Festspiele mit
Katharina Wagner beraten ob ihr Vertrag
verlängert wird beide Seiten stellen
Bedingungen und die Frage bleibt ob alle
Akteure dann in dieselbe Richtung zeigen
und zum Schluss noch etwas unnützes
Wissen Richard Wagner verfügte übrigens
dass der Parseval ausschließlich im
Bayreuther Festspielhaus aufgeführt
werden darf
und vielleicht ganz nützlich zu wissen
gegen 23 Uhr meldet sich hier im ZDF
wieder Nazan gökte mir mit unserem heute
journal Update und das war es von uns
beiden machen sie es gut auch immer sie
sind bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend bevor wir zum Wetter kommen
ein kurzer Blick auf die Zugspitze dort
hat heute eine der modernsten
Messstationen der Welt eine neue
forschungskuppel bekommen und während
hier zukünftig neueste Daten zum
Klimawandel gesammelt werden wurde
gleichzeitig der Sterbenden Gletscher
gedacht der südliche Schneeferner zum
Beispiel verlor im letzten Jahr schon
seinen Status als Gletscher so eisig saß
auf dem zugspitzblatt noch vor 130
Jahren aus der südliche und nördliche
schneeferne bildeten eine große
Gletscherlandschaft heute ist davon nur
noch wenig übrig die Ursache zu wenig
Schnee im Winter und zu viel Schmelze im
Sommer denn die Alpen haben sich durch
den Klimawandel seit 1902 Grad erwärmt
und bald werden die Gletscher der
Zugspitze ganz verschwinden
interaktiv können Sie in unserer heute
App selbst auf die Zugspitze klettern
und so noch mehr erfahren
auf der Zugspitze hat es heute übrigens
ein wenig geschneit denn die
Schneefallgrenze in den Hochalpen sinkt
jetzt auf um 2000 Metern und so geht es
dann auch in der Nacht dort mit
schneeweißer dann ein skandinavientief
lenkt aus Nordwesten höhenkalte Luft zu
uns im Rest des Landes sorgt das
verbreitet für Schauer und kurze
Gewitter und es kühlt eben ab heute
Nacht schon auf 14 bis 7 Grad oft
einstellig vor allem im Bergland dazu
gibt es im Süden und im Südosten weiter
diesen teils kräftigeren Regen anfangs
mit Gewittern zum Morgen entwickeln sich
dann auch im Nordwesten kurze Gewitter
und dann kommen wir zu dem Tag morgen in
dem sich blauer Himmel abwechseln mit
Schauern und Gewittern am wenigsten
davon gibt es im Osten hier ist die Luft
noch trockener dazu gibt es einen
lebhaften westlichen Wind und es bleibt
kühl bei nur 15 bis 22 Grad tschüss